[Music]
what up guys just in breaking news so by
the time you guys see us probably three
years old but le county city or le
county and LD city just issued a new
safer at home restrictions on businesses
and activities which means residents
should stay at home and participating
residence should stay at home when not
participating in essential activities
like shopping or being illegal
technically we are no you can go in a
sheltered place environment you have to
be at home though should we camp out we
need to bring our stuff cuz this just
happened right now yeah right literally
right now in a heater and it actually
goes up into effect at 11:59 tonight
oh we're not illegal yet not yet you got
some time and we got we got five hours
and it will last through April 19th
possibly long highs Oh a month once
there could be burgers and fight that's
the one thing can I just say it get a
fridge I'm so glad I got the essentials
[Music]
can you share we lost them so what sucks
is you can't leave your home unless it's
an essential activity like shopping for
food hardware supplies and medication
which little hardware supply JK news is
not essential activity no but how would
I know and there's a lot of people with
jobs throughout the state stuck at home
what are they still doing post meets
every ad takeout is okay post mates
driver I know we could make peanut
butter jelly sandwiches and we put them
a little trays and then we go to JK news
and then a couples over like I'm just
delivered or the door - or whatever yeah
we could do that this is gonna go rob a
post a traffic you butters jelly
sandwiches better than some places we
order from it JK news so true we're from
Jersey Mike's and we just bring that
sandwich here oh that's really good
that's way good yes what if we what if
we do some Jay King news episodes as
like a group chat like face chat may
come into that that's fine yeah at home
it's hard to talk over each other - yes
and then it'll be easy for the editors
cuz then there's just one screen and
that's it that's way fun so is that fun
for you we'll see we'll see how that hit
technically that'll work out you
promised the line okay so these are so
everyone has to practice which is
distance here gonna stay at home except
for the bees get ready for this grocery
stores supermarkets food banks farmer
markets schools child care centers law
yes
businesses and organizations that
provide food shelter social services I
think it's up to the schools if then
they themselves feel safe but they can't
most of it most were closed owner yes
this is including entertainment
I'll get to it so gas stations banks
financial institutions Harlan
telemedical order plumbers and
electricians media outlets can continue
to us yes that's crazy is it and then oh
come on tit
and laundromats and dry cleaners tip
this is my entire social life right now
so I understand and I get it I just I'm
being selfish I did yeah I wanted to
have a corona party with my friends it
was a bit insensitive people all right
also corona is all about everywhere cuz
everybody else had your idea for a bit
no no I'm talking about just having like
12 friends over but then I guess that's
but it's a having a specific you got a
12-pack of beer thanks what's my one
beer in one compact one beer each so the
reason why they want to put this into
effect is because the governor Gavin
Newsom he's saying that based on the
rate that is spreading right now an
eight week period 56 percent of the
state's population could be infected
wait what so they want to if they want
to put a cap on it right now six percent
I believe his hair so I was reading on
Twitter after this was announced
people were responding from Sacramento
that has happened a couple days ago for
them and it hasn't changed anything so
far like in terms of spreading yep no
people still people aren't abiding by it
going around it's hard to before it's
hard unfortunate sort of what's
happening with Miami right now where
people are screaming breaking it anyway
I think it's just sort of like a hey
guys it's a little more serious now and
so you're supposed to maybe man like to
stay home on your own volition right
what about all the National Guard's that
are being mobilized I think that because
I think it's gonna they're planning on
people not listening and so then they're
gonna have to make it stricter yeah so
like like in Italy like we're no you
know people weren't really abiding by it
and then now they're all did you go
through like a looting and rioting kind
of thing
no no no they generally say [ __ ] it
apparently get right into throwing
grandma's house that's the bro yeah
[ __ ] Italians it's the whole thing is
that there's so family-oriented I think
it pulled much sometimes guys you gotta
go you gotta go to your grandma
grandpa's house every [ __ ] day
apparently
and that's basically what happened is
that the the elderly there got seriously
[ __ ] because they're always Asian
between the younger generation and the
elderly generation and so you know
that's kind of a whole jam with them and
so yeah cuz like for here like we don't
really see [ __ ] no parents ever we don't
care that the bottom as much and we
don't infect them as much yes that well
because we're not Italians it's not part
of our culture all right anyone really
have a date night see them every single
day you care for them by not carrying
exactly what I still every lettin like
based language country has to do it
[Laughter]
[Music]
everyone know do Portuguese let me tell
you something what the Olive Garden okay
no same [ __ ] endless breadsticks but you
understand because you're here you're
family loophole is empathy Wow poor guys
yeah I don't know this is getting more
serious so do you think eventually we're
gonna get to Italy standards where
people are gonna get arrested
potentially it would be really cool if
it does get to that point and if media
outlets do are a are able to keep
meeting and keep providing services
maybe we can get little jakey badges so
that way when we're driving on the
street and they pull this off we're
going Jaime rescue anyone LAPD in real
life Jake again
Hey look we're doing ignorant news today
definitely wow that's a high bill like
well [ __ ] really believe me I heard that
if you I wish it'd be good they would
crack down a little bit harder because
like I heard that if you are an
isolation complete isolation for two
weeks then you if you test after that
two weeks you're no longer really
spreadable yeah incubation period is
gone yeah exactly it's two weeks but you
have to but no one's doing the full two
weeks so every time you go out to like
get something you're starting it over
it's March 19th I just Elba
got the karana he go he has shown that
he doesn't have any really serious
symptoms like he seems to have a mild
case right video of him to talking about
like he was like all black people no
matter what country you're in no matter
what there's this horrible rumors but I
get it like people Kenny he's like we
can't so there's so much misinformation
it might be way lower than that now
which is very heartening it's very good
enough like it might even be point eight
percent right or or under that so it's
not as bad hopefully as it seems right
now right I also don't want it to get
that bad amen I don't I don't want I
don't want 20% of the man died I don't
want to play with the potentiality oh
yeah like like oh you know that 3% well
now it's five because no one figured it
out and exactly kind of things well
right but but that's what the hope is
right is that enough people take it
seriously now yeah can you a scream and
KC space please Wow
they're falling apart but am I gonna go
ya know what because I mean ya know you
never Mickey's hands are always a Mac
you shouldn't do that you're bad person
he's you pointing at them with your
nails you been martínez you gone
anywhere no she's actually like being
pretty good I think she's also like like
you know the kids in class that follows
the rules so she's been really really
really good at every time I go to the
supermarket she treats it like I'm a
hero like I'm I'm taking one for the
team
always fine yeah wish my wife could do
that to you just leave on your own
you're like a cigar here man hey [ __ ]
you Ryan when I come home she treats me
like Oh like I just came back from war
you probably got something out there
Carrie exactly denied to Casey when he
gets home I spray with her the Brandon
like that I was like I'm going into the
wildlands and she's like whatever I'm
trying to get you pasta and all the
things you need I had to give him a
speech I was like see if I know how your
brain works if you see rice in the store
do not buy it we have so much rice we
have every type of rice we have a huge
thing of brown rice maybe huge thing of
a huge thing of pasta for my sauce but
don't buy rice coz he's like through a
rice it was like motherf ER we have so
much rice okay kai and I be completely
honest with you right now you're talking
about a war here right not dude I love
you so much but yeah what I after that I
found rice and I bought it where'd you
hide it I have it in my closet why we
have song and you by the way I don't buy
brown rice that huge thing of brown rice
is you I had to throw out your old brown
rice packages because when we moved you
had
huge things of brown rice that you never
touch you like brown rice why do you buy
it this is the best deal Ryan it was if
I've been it was a something ed knows
and this is all additional sick is deal
there was social distancing here what
are you doing we're meeting for media
outlets we have I got one back one day
you know what it would have been a
better deal not buying anything because
we have it all right are you happy they
married a bishop pair I'll see your
brown rice Casey thank you bye you've
got some TP for me
yeah we're just case because he actually
knows how to cook hey hey I'll give him
that
hey I'll get him that happily Steve made
brown rice like three days ago he had it
through the whole thing away well no you
gotta get order yourself a rice cooker
no I had one
[Music]